I just want to start on reports in the
Sun newspaper that a BBC presenter
according to the mum of somebody paid a
17 year old 35 000 pounds for explicit
pictures do you have any concerns about
the way this has been handled by the BBC
deeply concerning
the idea that you know some presenters
think that they act with impunity and
they can get away with these sorts of
things it does call into question the
the uh the ethics the investigations how
long these things take and the BBC but
also other broadcasters do need to get a
grip because we seem to Lurch from one
Scandal to another and more needs to be
done
the timing is important isn't it um
because according to this woman she
complete she complained to the BBC in
May but the presenter in question then
stayed on air for weeks after I think
that's the concerning thing that someone
makes a complaint a very serious
complaint and then puts on the Telly the
next night and they're still there and
that's not good enough that is not
treating people victims with respect and
that's why there needs to be a full
investigation but look I think this goes
beyond the BBC we had uh stories of was
it last month about uh Phillip Schofield
and you know there may be more to come
who knows but the investigations but
also the standards need to be reformed
and looked at again what do you mean by
that the standards need to be reformed
and looked at again well the
investigations need to be much swifter
action needs to be taken quicker when
there are serious complaints like this
but the standards at which presenters
operate just need to be much much higher
no one should be able to get away with
this sort of thing and think they can
get away with it and that's clearly what
a lot of people seem to think today do
you think then that because presenters
are in the public eye in some ways
they're public figures that they should
be held to a different standard then
I think if anybody did this in any job
whether a teacher a doctor a television
presenter or politician it wouldn't be
acceptable but when serious allegations
are made like this I don't think it's
right that those people stay in those
jobs whilst there's very serious
investigations uh go on do you think
that the individual should be named
we've seen other presenters having to
come out to say that it's not them for
example
I'm not totally sure
um about that because you can get
vexatious complaints but that means
there's a greater illness on doing these
things quickly they shouldn't drag on
for months and months the BBC or whoever
the um the employer is needs to quickly
do these investigations and take the
appropriate action and I'm not convinced
so far that that's happened in this case
do you think this should be a police
element to this as well um if you look
for example the 1978 protection for
children act it's an offense to make
distribute possess or show any indecent
images of anyone age under 18. I think
this is a question that the
investigation needs to get into but
obviously it's deeply concerning the
idea that this was happening when the
young person was just 17 years old okay
thank you very much and now you are our
lead interview this morning because
according to the polls you could be the
second most important politician after
the next election so I just want to
start as well with one of the big Matic
stories if I may you know the U.S
President Joe Biden arriving in the UK
later
now we know the U.S want to send cluster
bombs to Ukraine is that something you
support
we all agree that Ukraine needs to be
properly armed to fight Russia and their
illegal Invasion but I am concerned
about the use of cluster bombs and it's
not just the UK who has these concerns
other countries clearly do as well and
so I would like to find a way to
properly arm Ukraine but without using
these weapons which can have an impact
not just on the battlefield at that time
on on that day but for months and years
afterwards that is something that caused
me deep concern and many other people as
well so while I support President
Biden's desire to ensure that Ukraine is
fully armed to fight Russia I'm not
convinced that these are the appropriate
weapons the UK of course Banning their
use because they so often kill a ninja
this is exactly the point that the
problem with cluster bombs is that they
don't all explode straight away and they
can explode later and that's why there's
such a danger to civilian life so that
is the specific issue around cluster
bombs look America has done more than
any other country in the world to ensure
that Ukraine is properly armed to fight
um Russia
um we all welcome that and should be
very grateful to the support that
America has given but I think it is
right that the Allies should be able to
say we're not sure about this and on the
issue of cluster bombs that is not
something that I would be able to
endorse would you like wishes you know
to raise it with President Biden later
then I welcomed what the Prime Minister
said yesterday when he was asked about
the use of cluster bombs I'm sure it
will be on the agenda this week but look
I think we should also pay tribute to
what the U.S has done during the course
of this war in ensuring that Ukraine is
properly armed Britain has played its
part as well but America more than any
other Nation has helped to ensure that
Russia can fight this um the Ukraine can
fight Russia in this illegal War now
that's just one other story that I'd
like your view on before we can move on
to your vision for the economy which of
course that's why you're here
George Osborne his wedding was disrupted
yesterday when a protester threw orange
confetti over him we think it may be
just a boiler that they haven't
completely claimed credit for it if you
like what's your reaction to what
happened I've got no time for just stop
oil to be honest I think it's a bit
pathetic and quite tedious uh disrupting
a tennis a snooker other people's
weddings you know if they want to tackle
climate change engage in the policy
answers but they're not building support
for their cause they're doing the exact
opposite so it's counterproductive and
and it's rude frankly you know people
paid to go to Wimbledon it may be
they're one time in their life that they
get to Wimbledon they don't want to be
disrupted by a load of protesters
um and you know look I care passionately
about tackling the climate emergency
it's why labor set out our green
Prosperity plan to reduce bills to Boost
energy security to get jobs in Britain
and to pass on to our children and
grandchildren a better Planet but that
is through practical policy not through
disrupting other people's lives that's
not the way to do it according to the
Sunday Times kirst armor said this week
I'm not interested in Tree Huggers in
fact I hate them well what's your stance
on tree huggers
uh look I love a tree uh what I don't
like is um needless disruption to
people's lives and the idea that you're
going to get closer to tackling the
climate emergency by stopping working
people getting to their jobs by training
yourselves to uh to Bridges by
disrupting sporting events I think again
frankly you know there's better ways to
tackle the climate emergency you're not
helping you're actually making things
worse okay that's very clear
um right let's talk about the economy
shall we you're announcing some housing
plans today what's the idea
most people dream of owning their own
home certainly most families do and yet
that dream for too many is slipping
further Out Of Reach and indeed for
others who have managed to get on the
housing ladder that dream is now turning
to a nightmare because of the Tory
mortgage bombshell that means people
coming off fixed rate mortgage deals are
seeing their average payments go up by
250 pounds a month we've set out plans
to help people with their mortgages
during this crisis to help with the
private renters Charter for those who
are stuck in the private rented sector
but the truth is we need more than
sticking plasters we need to start
building homes so that young people and
families can realize those dreams of
home ownership and that is what I'm
setting up today but it's also part of a
wider package of measures that I
describe as secure anomics it's about
securing family finances so that working
people can realize their dreams and
Ambitions home ownership is going
backwards under the conservatives it is
now clear that for people who dream of
owning their own home it is the labor
party that is on your side
about what a labor
economy would look like because it feels
to me like you talk an awful lot right
about the problems with the country the
housing crisis that you talk about there
you say you want to get State schools on
par with the private sector the NHS
you've spoken about at length and you
also say you want to keep the public
finances under control I mean that I'm
just trying to square these things off
you know if your chance lost their next
election you're going to inherit a
really difficult situation I think we
could have a look at the current
government spending projections from the
office of budget responsibility and you
can see a squeeze happening
post their next election which we
believe could be next year
are you going to stick to these spending
plans set out by the office of budget
responsibility well we're likely to have
two more forecasts from the office of
budget responsibility before the next
election so I don't think we should be
fixated with any particular current
forecast because they'll be updated two
more times before we get to the next
election there's no contradiction
between being fiscally responsible and
wanting to support public services in
fact I just kind of just support Public
Services unless you put fiscal economic
responsibility at the heart of
everything you do it's very important
you want to do to have that fiscal
responsibility is that credibility if
you say now before the 1997 election
Gordon Brown promised to stick to the
conservative party's spending plans for
the first two years are you gonna do the
same
is too far ahead of an election to set
out at those plans as I say there's
going to be probably two more uh
forecasts so another budget another
Autumn statement before so you won't say
whether you'll spend more or less well
we've already set out as you know Sophie
some specific tax Rises so for example
if you make Britain your home I believe
you should pay your taxes here and under
a labor government you will that's why
we'll get rid of the non-dom tax status
about 3.5 billion pounds a year and we
would use that money to invest in our
NHS Workforce you had Steve Barclay
Sophie on this program last week and you
rightly said to him you've set out an
NHS Workforce plan but you haven't set
out how you would pay for it labor have
we've said that we would pay for that
expansion of the number of training
places for doctors for nurses The
Midwives of Health Visitors by getting
rid of that non-domline we also pay the
NHS workers uh what they what the
independent pay of your body would like
to see as well six percent pay rise will
we haven't actually seen the
recommendations yet of the pay review so
we understand it will be well look let's
I would urge the government to publish
that so that we can have a debate about
it would you will you accept whatever
they recommend or again I'm not going to
have a uh you know a negotiation on the
Telly uh for public sector wages
and not being open about you know what
they'll do what they how they're going
to pay which is a huge part of the
budget I haven't seen whether or not
you'll accept the pay Rises that the
pay-per-view bodies recommend we haven't
seen those pay Rises and I'm certainly
not going to sign up to something before
even seeing it but the recommendations
of the payee review bodies should then
be taken into negotiation between
working people the trade unions that
represent them you know my mum and dad
were both Primary School teachers I know
how hard people in the public service
work including our teachers our doctors
our nurses they deserve to be treated
with respect and part of that respect is
going and the negotiating table and
that's being paid well it's not going
around the negotiating table they don't
care if you're around the table or not
you're going to say are they absolutely
care about whether they're going to get
paid a wage that's going to allow them
to that's absolutely do care about being
treated with respect and one of the
things that the teachers and the nursing
unions have said is that they want the
government to get around the table and
negotiate not just pay but also workload
retention recruitment it's by Bridget
Phillipson for example has said for
teachers specifically there should be
some more support for newly qualified
teachers including a bonus payment so
there are practical things that we can
do with for example getting rid of that
non-dom status also by having VAT on
private schools that would raise around
1.6 billion pounds
3.6 billion I mean you're talking about
spending 28 billion pounds in the green
Prosperity
there's billions of pounds up billions
of pounds Sophie that will be spent on
Pub Public Services through targeted tax
increases getting rid of the non-dom tax
status getting a vat on private school
fees to help all of our state schools
and also with private Equity treating
their bonuses like income and taxing it
accordingly now before you enter
politics you used to work at Bank of
England it's been an awful lot of
criticism about how the bank of England
has handled the inflation crisis
particularly that they were too slow to
put up interest rates at the beginning
what's your own View
well I worked at the bank of England for
many years before I became a member of
Parliament and one of the things about
that relationship now between the
treasury and the bank of England is that
they have operational Independence and
the respect for those Economic
Institutions is absolutely is that not a
bit of a concern I know right I
understand they're independent but if
the government can't pass any comment at
all about what one of our most important
institutions government is carrying
governments can Sophie last summer Liz
truss and cozy quatting past no end of
judgment on Economic Institutions they
sacked the permanent secretary at the
treasury they undermine the independence
of the bank of England and they didn't
let the officer budget responsibility do
their forecast that is part of the
reason that we had the disastrous
response to the mini budget that saw
mortgage rates go through the roof
let me just finish this point respect
for Economic Institutions is a huge part
of the economic stability that we've
enjoyed in the UK and you mess with that
with your peril is it right that you're
considering changes to the the monetary
policy committee that the people who
decide on interest no are quite more
diverse or to get a wider range of
people in there I would like to see a
more a diverse range of people making
Economic Policy we've had a chancellor
of the exchequer for 800 years it's
never been a woman there's never been a
a woman governor of the bank of England
either I would like to see more
diversity
economic policy making I hope to break
that glass ceiling next year and become
the first female Chancellor of the
ex-chequer in 800 years and I would use
that opportunity and that role to reduce
some of those inequalities in society
like the fact that it's more than 50
years since a Barbara Castle introduced
the Equal Pay Act and yet there's still
a 15 gap between what men and women are
paid in our economy so what I'm just
what would you do what about the
monetary policy committee would you try
and make it more diverse I'm not
actually clear
but I would like to see more diversity
but you've got to get the the best
people for the job I think more diverse
groups of people make better decisions
but you've got to respect Economic
Institutions if you don't you end up in
the mess that Liz truss and
quasiquarting ended in last year which
has brought our economy close to
collapse
I've we're nearly running out of time
but there's just one thing I quite want
to ask you at the end about your
relationship with kirstama if you look
at Prime Ministers and their chancellors
it's their relationship is always quite
interesting like if you have a
productive relationship it almost seems
to me like you have to get on but
there've got to be points of tension as
well you've got to bring different
perspectives to that role and I just
wonder you know frankly you in case time
to feel pretty similar is there anything
you disagree on football is obsessed
with it and I have no interest in it
whatsoever uh
look you know obviously we've got our
own jobs to do my job is to make sure
that the numbers uh add up but here is
fully absolutely supportive of that
because but he knows that there's no
shortcuts do you ever have a row over
something where he's saying look we've
got to do this you're pulling in a
different direction or are you always in
lockstep on everything we're in lockstep
he recognizes Kia recognizes the
importance of the the rock of Economic
and fiscal responsibility must underpin
everything that we do and I think that
results in in better decision making and
people know that we are fully aligned on
the big issues that are going to
confront us if we have the opportunity
to serve after the next election okay
thank you very much